help me understand something A.D because
you know I'm from Arizona I was just out
it's my second home you know I love
Scottsdale you do love you some
Scottsdale I got to get you to my new
club bro congratulations on that man
wait wait you're doing it with my with
my guys um Cory Cory and uh Davion
they're my guys man shout out to them
yeah yeah I'll be out there Thursday
you know I was I was eating at a
Filibertos at about 4 30 in the morning
last weekend and I thought to myself
for lab in La why is there no [__]
real [__] all-night food popping
isn't that [__] crazy like I can't go
get a burrito at 4 45 in the morning in
L.A the taco trucks are all closed the
valley you can
wear crave [__] Crave Cafe where the
[__] is that bro [__] this is literally
is there a driver there's like three of
them out here is there a drive-through
no drive then [__] out of here I want to
drive through and give me a [__]
California Burrito at four in the
morning true and it's like it's La you
can post made it
the Great White Hut that they just
opened is it good
it's good enough because it's the only
[__] thing you can get food from
guess what it's a drive-through no no
drive through there's a certain [__]
about La that really bothers me because
it's LA and it should be like should be
booming it should be all night I should
be able to go get food
I should have more options than Jack in
the Box is all I'm saying I know I'd be
trying to like let me hear him go to the
Hibachi truck before you know I mean
open it all what do you I think if I was
telling us about this I was like bro I'm
trying to open up all night just 24 7
spot because I feel like it would boom
out here it would though because they're
not there's nothing do you think there's
any like restrictions against that
that's why I don't do it I don't know I
just know I live in Burbank and the
Armenians be closing down early bird
early yeah
because I can't get nothing I gotta go
to Jack In The Box you live in Burbank
Jason are you worried about bringing
people to your house when you do the
stream no because everybody that I bring
like I trust with my life anyway and
everybody everybody okay
and it honestly honestly like I don't
live in in fear and if it has to go
there I'm prepared for it because I had
like a huge I bought a new house in
Burbank and I have like this huge
building behind my house and I was like
I could totally do the podcast right
here I was like well [__] that [__] well
that's kind of like what you know the
goal is now is to buy a compound and buy
a hub so we don't have to just bring
everything to your crib